.
>> Bret: BILL MELUGIN IN DEL
RIO, TEXAS.
THANK YOU.
LET'S TAKE A CLOSER LOOK HOW THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS HANDLING
THE RENEWED FOCUS ON THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
HERE IS WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY.
>> A RARE ADMISSION FROM THIS
WHITE HOUSE.
THEY KNOW THE HEADLINES ARE BAD.
>> WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF
NAVIGATING AND WEATHERING STORMS
AND DEALING WITH CRISES THAT'S
WHAT A PRESIDENT SHOULD DO.
>> U.S. ENVOY FOR HAITI WANTS
OUT.
DANIEL FOOT RESIGNED WITH THIS
LETTER.
I WILL NOT BE ASSOCIATED WITH
THE UNITED STATES INHUMANE
COUNTER PRODUCTIVE DECISION TO
DEPORT HOW SANDS OF HAITIAN
REFUGEES AND IMMIGRANTS TO HAITI
A COUNTRY AMERICAN OFFICIALS ARE
CONFINED TO SECURE COMPOUNDS
BECAUSE OF THE DANGER POSED BY
ARMED GANGS TO DAILY LIFE.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS PUSHING BACK.
>> FIRST I WOULD NOTE THERE HAVE
BEEN MULTIPLE SENIOR LEVEL
POLICY CONVERSATIONS ON HAITI.
WHERE ALL PROPOSALS, INCLUDING
THOSE LED BY SPECIAL ENVOY
FOOTEE WERE FULLY CONSIDERED.
SOME OF THOSE WERE CONSIDERED
HARMFUL TO THE COMMITMENT OF
PROMOTION OF DEMOCRACY IN HAITI.
>> PROGRESSIVES ARE STILL UPSET
ROUNDED BYE BYE BORDER PATROL
OFFICERS PATROLS THAT HAVE SINCE
BEEN SUSPENDED.
>> WHAT WE WITNESSED WAS WORSE
THAN WHAT WE WITNESSED IN
SLAVERY.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE IS HOPING TO
COOL CRITICISM.
>> I THINK CONGRESSWOMAN WATERS
AND OTHERS AS ARE WE HAVE BEEN
HORRIFIED BY THE PHOTOS OF THE
BORDER PATROL OFFICERS AND THAT
BEHAVIOR.
>> INCOME FROM THE LEFT IS
UNCOMMON FOR THIS PRESIDENT.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN GETTING
ATTACKED FROM BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE IS BECAUSE HE CAN'T GET A
HANDLE ON THIS SITUATION.
>> TO CLEAR THE CAMP IN DEL RIO,
THE FEDS ARE BUSING MIGRANTS TO
PARTS OF TEXAS OR FLYING THEM TO
ARIZONA.
AND UNLESS THEY SHOW SYMPTOMS,
NO COVID TEST.
>> WHY SHOULD SOMEBODY, SAY, IN
LAREDO OR EL PASO OR TUCSON,
ARIZONA HAVE TO HAVE THEIR
CHANCE OF CATCHING COVID GO UP
BECAUSE HUNDREDS OF MILES AWAY
THERE IS AN OPEN BORDER.
>> WELL, THERE CERTAINLY IS NOT
AN OPEN BORDER.
>> THERE IS ACCORDING TO SOME
TEXAS LAWMAKERS.
>> MOST OF THESE HAITIANS ARE
FROM BRAZIL.
THEY GOT WORD OF THE FACT WITH
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WE HAVE
AN OPEN BORDER POLICY COME ON
IN.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT BIDEN
SAID TWO YEARS AGO.
>> WE ARE A IMMIGRATION SAYS IF
YOU WANT TO FLEE AND YOU ARE
FLEEING OPPRESSION YOU SHOULD
COME.
>> WHEN THE PRESIDENT SAID THAT,
PROGRESSIVES CHEERED.
BUT NOW THE PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY
COMING, PROGRESSIVES ARE TELLING
HIM YOU'VE GOT TO TREAT THESE
MIGRANTS BETTER.
AND PRESIDENT BIDEN IS SAYING
NOTHING.
NO PUBLIC EVENTS ON THE SCHEDULE
TODAY.